die Haltung soll reduziert werden um
Fleisch sozusagen aus dem Markt zu
drängen in den Münchner Kitas haben die
Grünen durchgesetzt dass keine Wurst
kein Fleisch kein Fisch mehr angeboten
wird und das da wird schon ein kleiner
Kampf darüber geführt Angeboten
Angeboten
nein ich habe es von mir aus gesagt nein
nein das ist ja also es ist so also die
Kinder
mitbringen aber das bietet die Kita
nicht mann das ist eine
Grundsatzentscheidung ich finde im 1%
Veganer wir haben 7% Vegetarier finde
ich alles gut aber diese
umerziehungswünsche die ist von einigen
gibt die lehnen wir halt ab und ich
finde das selber
entscheiden Wasser ist und was er